this is a production of Cornell
University
okay hi so my name is Leila corny and
I'm going to talk to you about a project
that I've been working on regarding
biologically as thermo chemically
altered human waste converting it to
into fertilizers and soil conditioners I
became involved in this project through
a broader initiative that was put out by
the Gates Foundation called to reinvent
the toilet challenge I was sort of very
low on the totem pole in terms of people
that were involved there was a project
called the climate foundation which was
awarded one of these prizes for
developing a pyrolysis based toilet so
it's a toilet that takes the solid waste
and converts it into charcoal and they
contacted Johannes lemon and they asked
him to be involved and then I somehow
got involved and and the goal of this of
this call was to was to generate waste
management systems that are off the grid
so basically non water-based waste
management systems particularly which is
particularly important in developing
countries where sometimes the population
density and informal settlements of so
high you can't even put in
infrastructure and obviously you know
one of the objectives is to remove germs
and recover valuable resources such as
energy clean water and nutrients and
this is where johannes and i came into
the project we were working on
converting the Charter or assessing
whether the charcoal was a valuable
resource with regards to nutrients and
the and all project proposals had to
demonstrate that their plan cost less
than five cents per user per day and it
was supposed to promote sustainable
services in poor urban settings so this
is this is a context in which I I've
been working on my dissertation and this
is the physical context in which I
worked for about a year in Kenya this is
a picture from Kabara it's one of the
most I guess like renowned or nefarious
I don't know slums in in Kenya it's not
the biggest and it's not the worst but
but this is a this is a common sight
because waste management is generally by
justin disposal so open defecation open
dumping and what you have is a problem
with an excess of nutria
but actually this problem with an excess
of nutrients in urban areas is common
all around the world I think we all
understand that there's a decoupling
between the nutrients generated and you
know concentrated areas of human
environment or or where animals are
produced where animals are grown and
areas where crops are grown I mean even
in the Northeast you have this problem
where areas were they were there are
large dairy farms you have a large
concentration of nutrients in areas
where people are growing maize they are
applying tons of mineral fertilizer
because there's this decoupling and this
is particularly prominent in developing
countries where there's absolutely no
way so there's no waste treatment at all
it just goes into the ambient
environment it just stays in the
waterways around Nairobi and this
problem of excess it manifests as excess
pathogens and health problems excess
nutrients loading into the water and
excess greenhouse gases whereas over in
western Kenya where a lot of the maize
is grown you have the opposite problem
we have a deficiency how the soil
fertility deficiencies people can't
afford to buy new fertilizers I don't
have access to them which result in
yield deficiencies and they cause human
nutritional deficiencies and here you
can see what a little bit of fertilizer
can do for a crop this is a maize plot
that's not receiving receiving any
fertilizer and this is a maize crop
that's receiving only 80 kilograms of
nitrogen per hectare and so if we could
just try to couple these systems take
some of this excess and put it here we
might really you know be on our way with
helping people and so and so our
collaborators on the ground in Kenya
that were also involved in this project
are a latrine project started by some
MIT business students that basically
recognized a business opportunity in
waste management in the slum called
stanner G and you know their business
model is to Co sanitize waste by
collecting it transforming it which is
our what we're in the business of
transforming waste and generating energy
either energy or some valuable product
and they're so they're located in
nairobi kenya and they're the train
system it operates it's it's called a
urine diversion system where the solid
waste is collected and one portion of
the liquid waste in one and that's very
important when you're sanitizing waste
because most canonization processes in
all heat I mean there are some that
don't like anaerobic digestion or fatty
acids things that large engine is Labs
is working on but our methods thermo
chemically transferring waste and also
compensation they they necessitate heat
and so you don't want you want as low of
a water content as possible and and also
what you get r22 resources you get the
solid portion of the waste and the
liquid portion of the waste and they
have different benefits when they're
processed properly and that presents
energy is only processing ways through
compensation and that's sort of where we
came in we were trying to see if
pyrolysis was another maybe a more
actually a more efficient solution for
them and I just wanted to so this is
from their website so at present I just
downloaded this yesterday they they have
932 active toilets they sell the
latrines to people that then operate
them by pay it's like fifteen cents to
use them and then they have about 50,000
users a day so I'm going to use that
number to calculate some basically what
the potential nutrient recovery would be
from these 50,000 I call them fresh life
Cooper's because the latrines are called
fresh life latrine so here is somebody
using a fresh light latrine and he's
generating on average 50 grams of dry
human waste per day that's sort of the
values are all over in the literature
but this is what we we measured at
Sanergy this is what we measured coming
out of the latrines based on the people
that we're using them and in that 50
grams of dry human waste today based on
the nitrogen phosphorus and potassium
content that I measured we can generate
about 1.4 grams of nitrogen point 5
grams of phosphorus 0.5 grams of
potassium and in the urine two people
generally excrete about one liter a day
which on a mass per volume basis about
one percent nitrogen point seven percent
phosphorous is 2 percent point two
percent potassium we have 10 grams of
mineral nitrogen 7 grams phosphorous two
grams of potassium so we add that up and
we want to convert that into how many
farms we can fertilize per year from
those 50,000 fresh life poopers so what
we get over one year if we just account
for the nitrogen in the urine which we
know is plant available we go to 130
eighty three tons per year just from
those 50,000 people 155 tons of
it's 46 tons of potassium and with that
we can fertilize these are some new
trick the the fertilizer nutrient
recommendations for the Ministry of
Agriculture I understand that that's
very low but but you have to understand
that people are applying zero so 90
kilograms is a lot for a farmer in
western Kenya we can fertilize over two
thousand farms a year just using these
fifty thousand people
sorry just using the waste generated
from these fifty thousand people and
that's great so another question is well
why pyrolysis there's so many other ways
to sanitize waste you can just do
composting you can do anaerobic
digestion you can do this incinerate but
the thing about pyrolysis is that first
of all I think you understand that
people are interested in it because of
its energy this is its efficiency with
regards to energy it's kind of
exothermic to a certain point under
certain conditions but I think in this
context it's important to consider that
right now energy they're just using
composting so these are wind rose at
Sanergy and you have to get for thermal
Fela compensation to work you have to
get up to sixty degrees Celsius and
there really is actually a kind of a
cold place it's like high up it rains a
lot and they I've been told that they
can rarely get above 55 degree Celsius
we have to leave it out for about nine
months
but with pyrolysis these temperatures
assure sanitization and a very short
time you know was in a day I mean the
goal of the of the reinvent the toilet
project the people we were working with
was to convert to tons of wasted day
into charge like that was so you know
like the plan and the anoxic conditions
so pyrolysis is like incineration with
no oxygen the and ice conditions reduce
carbon so so carbon becomes reduced and
less I mean I you know less microbial
available or more persisted in soil and
it concentrates nutrients because what
goes off during the process is carbon
oxygen hydrogen and you get a
concentration of the plant essential
nutrients it requires obviously less
time and less land than compensation and
I wanted to show this data just because
I know that there are a lot of issues
with bio solids and I'm not for bio
solids and this is not bio solids this
is not mixed with industrial waste and I
wanted to also show you that the problem
with pollutants in Kenya is not coming
from people I will disregard with
regards to heavy metals obviously you
know
did not measure xenobiotics and anyways
with pyrolysis that would be a problem
but with regards to heavy metals just
leaving the waste in the environment
increases the concentration of lead and
arsenic relative to treating it
immediately and this was what we did we
took the computed immediately we have
much lower lead concentrations than the
compost that was sitting out for months
and that's just because of the ambient
environment very polluted in Nairobi and
so the treatment met the the treatment
methods that I'll be talking about in
this presentation I called a biological
sanitization which is composting there
are other methods for Biological
standardization like anaerobic digestion
which I'm not going to talk about and
I'm going to talk about thermo chemical
methods so including Tora faction at
200° but this doesn't really alter the
chemistry of the material it mostly
serves sedessa kated but it's still you
know an toxic and you considered that
and pyrolysis which is thermo chemical
transformation between 300 and 700
degrees Celsius so the research
questions that I'm going to address
right now are let's start with the first
one which properties of treated human
waste have adverted values so what is it
about this material that might improve
crop yields I mean is that the surface
areas of the phosphors of the nitrogen
is that something you know rhizobia I
didn't test all these things with but I
just interested in getting an idea of is
there anything valuable adultress
material and particularly I wanted to
try to convert some of the agronomic
properties into a monetary value
relative to fertilize the price of
fertilizer and I try to quantify not
just the nutrients but also what I
considered to be soil conditioning
properties I was also interested in
whether the nitrogen the phosphorus is
available in these different amendments
and soils and whether it differs across
soil so if I incubate these amendments
and soils what happens to nitrogen and
phosphorus availability and so to that
end I incubated them in soils that
differed in pH and texture and my third
objectives
having a general idea that most of the
nitrogen in the waste was probably not
plan available I wanted to see if I
could incorporate the nitrogen and urine
into pyrolyze human waste to produce a
high-value soil amendment knowing that
nitrogen is first and foremost the most
limiting nutrient obviously there are so
many other limiting nutrients but I feel
like you know the
Oh hanging fruit of taking care of a lot
of plant issues is adding nitrogen and
so I tried to develop a process for
precipitating nitrogen from year and
into pyrolyze human waste not relying on
necessarily the chemical properties of
the waste was just trying to create a
solution environment that that could
happen within which that could happen so
here my first objective determined the
agronomic properties and values of human
solid waste so when I say Granata
properties I'm talking about things like
plant essential nutrients like
phosphorus magnesium calcium I'm also
talking about properties like liming it
can this material consume acidity
does it have carbonate it's sort of
embedded in the matrix what about
nutrient retention is it's or being you
know calcium what about nitrogen and
also is it a source of stable carbon and
stable carbon is important we know from
you know like soil health because it
actually affects these things liming a
nutrient retention but it also is
important from an environmental
perspective we want to mitigate the
oxidation of waste because at this point
the wastage is going into the ambient
environment and completely oxidizing or
being converted to methane
I would like to stabilize some of that
cart carbon so we want the goal is to
take this weak little plant add a little
charcoal and get a nice looking plant
alright so to start I had to I had to
create some human waste charcoal so me
and some people not this guy but some
other people we well I took this from
the internet but we we collected some
way so these are the buckets that you
collect the solid waste and from the
toilets and the jerry cans is a urine we
collected that and I just want you to
know that it's very but the human waste
is very different than like bio solids
which has a very high concentration of
mica of bacteria because it's you know
under undergoes digestion and it's not
like Pig waste because it's actually
because of the way that people use the
latrines they put sawdust the cover
material it's mixed with sawdust like
mostly eucalyptus at a one-to-one Drive
volumetric ratio and so looks like this
and it's sort it's a little bit more
like animal like like cow manure almost
like the texture and so we had the Sun
dryer to get it below 35 percent
moisture because again we're thermo
chemically transforming it so we need to
have as low of a water cond as possible
we pyrolyze it in a unit that actually
kiyo sent to the collaborators and then
we did some analyses and those analyses
included we extracted macronutrients so
well first of all we extracted nitrogen
with potassium chloride we wanted to get
the the plant available nitrogen on just
the total nitrogen and then we did we
just did a male if extraction of these
macronutrients and these micronutrients
very simple just to get a sort of a
proxy for what the nutrient availability
would be in this material and then and
then and then I looked at the soil
conditioning properties which again I I
determined would be the liming potential
which is I calculated as the calcium
carbonate equivalents li using a back
titration with sodium hydroxide and then
I try to quantify I basically use the
cation exchange capacity to assess how
how much how much of the base cations in
the material could be retained over time
and I tried to quantify that turn that
into a metric that that actually is just
in in milligrams per kilogram of
nutrients and then I quant I tried to
quantify the stable carbon expected to
remain after a hundred years I called it
BC plus 100 using a metric which is the
content the molar concentration of
hydrogen two organic carbon which is
sort of like a metric for the aromatic
carbon versus aliphatic carbon so it's
something it's the carbon that the
organic carbon that you would expect to
remain in the soil and this is this what
I got so this top graph the y-axis is
the is the nutrient concentration in
each Amendment amendments being the
compost the torrefied ways the two
pyrolyzed weights at two different
degrees the nutrients being the
extractable nitrogen these these
nutrients micronutrients
and then CEC is the contribution of CEC
towards nutrients by retaining what the
potassium calcium magnesium that's
already in the soil and I have a
calculation for that and I didn't show
that I can show anyone that's interested
so what I can see here is that as I
increase with highest heating
temperature I have more nutrients
because because the the nutrients become
concentrated because actually there's a
yield loss of mass loss with as the
product is
subjected to thermal treatment so at 500
degrees I actually only am retaining 30%
of the original mass and most of what's
lost is carbon oxygen and hydrogen so
the nutrients are concentrated
nevertheless even though I still lost
you know maybe 70% of the carbon and
hydrogen and oxygen and still I still
have well I didn't lose Sony because I
can still have 70% according to this
metric of what could be considered
persistent carbon in this material
compared to all the other materials and
so in so in conclusion the pyrolized
human weighs 500 degrees it contains
about 15% more nutrients and torrefied
waste 100 percent more nutrients and
composted waste and about 600 percent
more stable carbon than either of these
and that can translate into a monetary
value and now we're going to calculate
that so to calculate to put a dollar
sign i i i just took fertilizer and lime
prices from different sites from this
really nice site that has prices for
fertilizers in east africa as well as
international prices and good old
alibaba
and i also calculated the I try to put
$1 percent on the stable carbon using
discount prices from a World Bank report
that I used you know 20 different
countries to average out what a carbon
discount rate would be and the the
amount of money per amendment is
basically the summed value of all the
agronomic components including the
nutrients including the line me
including the stable carbon and again I
mean as you got you guys know with
prices especially when you're talking
about Africa International over time
there's a huge sensitivity of the
amendment value on on the market prices
and so the quartile values are really
you know all over the place so I just
looked at the median market price for
all of these nutrients so what I got is
this so first of all I just want to say
so that so the y-axis is US dollars per
ton per ton of what so here it's per ton
of feed stuff per ton of the initial
waste before it's treated with anything
so everything's been normalized to what
I call they yield like like the math
yield coming out of the out of the
treatment process and so what you can
see is as the material is subject to
higher heating there's more mass lost
and that decreases the value of the
waste respect it basically it's what the
waste processing plant seeds of what
they feel they feel they have
material they're getting less money
because they have this mass loss this is
US dollars per amendment per because us
always four ton of amendment of the
final product this is what the farmer
sees so if you give a farmer a bag of
this this is what they see they see all
this phosphorus and potassium and so it
has a very high value but they're also
not paying for the overhead cost so I
just want to demonstrate that there are
two ways to put a dollar value on this
product it's either what is in the hands
of the farmer that would otherwise have
been buying fertilizer or what is in the
hands of the waste processing that has
to sell the amendment and if you are
just the farmer you'd much rather have
the the higher temperature material
because it has more nutrients in it and
you're going to save money if you're the
waste processing plant you'd much rather
process this material because you're
getting more money per unit map that
you're collecting and I also want to
point out that there's really like the
big difference here is just between the
thermochemical treatments and the
biological treatment I mean it's just
completely different and I think that's
because the compost is not really like
the feedstock anymore I think it's been
contaminated with soil it has a very
high concentration of iron aluminum and
manganese because it's sort of been
mixed in the wind rows whereas the 200
degree material is almost is the most
similar to the feedstock so I just think
that the constant process fundamentally
changes the maturing they all
fundamentally change the material but to
in an undesirable way so anyways so in
Africa and by the way these are
fertilizer prices the prices through
which these were generated were taken
from the African fertilizer prices not
the International although it's all
insane websites and so in Africa a ton
of human solid waste process at 500
degrees would give me two hundred
forty-five dollars mostly from
phosphorus and potassium so the value of
thermo chemically treated waste is more
than four times the composted waste now
I just wanted to show this just to
compare what the price international
prices are and to show that the value is
really different where you are in the
world like the value of your waist looks
different if you're in the United States
where you can buy fertilizer prices
using the International on the
international market or whether you're
in Africa
so for a 500-degree waste in Africa you
might think that that bag that ton of
material is saving you 245 dollars
whereas here at $61 with 61 dollars why
would I even bother
and and potassium and phosphorous are
disproportionately higher in Africa than
some of the other fertilizer prices
so in conclusion
pyrolyzed wastes at 500 degrees has the
highest nutrient concentration cell
conditioning properties now this is not
very impressive but if I just generated
an extractable NPK value I have zero
nitrogen 0.8 percent phosphorus and 1%
to calcium now again when you talk about
organic amendments usually they're
presented in the total elemental
concentration not in P 2 O 5 or K 2 O so
you know this is not that bad for it B
extractable and it has a hundreds and
higher nutrients on the compost 50%
higher than the torrefied waste but now
I want to talk about the money that
we're getting so this is what Sanergy
sees this is if I was processing waste
this is the kind of money I'd be making
if I was collecting this way so they are
collecting the waste I don't know and
they are selling the compost and the
urine I but I don't really know what
they're selling it for but according to
my estimations those 50,000 people using
their toilets for generating 50 grams of
dry waste a day at a 30 percent mass
recovery for the 500 degree treatment
only give me point seven five tonnes of
waste and if this is a price per ton I
only get $190 every day from those fifty
thousand people but if I use the 200
degree processing method I have 90
percent mass recovery because it's tore
affection only dehydrates the waste and
I'm assuming I've already dried it down
to begin with is 50 grams of dry weight
so I get a lot more money I look I get
five hundred eighty two dollars a day so
this I think these values I mean for for
a program that's trying to implement
this it as an intervention that you have
to really consider who you know who
these prices are for they're there for
the processing plant of the farmer so my
second objective we already know we've
gone over this agronomic value now we're
going to look at do different human
solid waste amendments affect soil
nitrogen and phosphorus
different ways in different soils and so
I incubated them these amendments and
soil differing and texture and pH and pH
so my hypothesis was that where that I
would see a trade-off with the available
nitrogen and the available phosphorus
with highest heating temperature there's
a lot of literature to demonstrate that
so I thought well I would surely see
that as well so I'd lower the products
that were subjected to lower
temperatures like the compost in the
torrefied ways they would probably
generate a lot of nitrogen whereas the
pyrolized ways especially the 500-degree
would probably have a lot of phosphorous
definitely low respiration stabilized
carbon and would probably have a high pH
I also wanted to see what would happen
if I incubated the 500 degree material
the biochar with urine assuming that a
lot of this nitrogen isn't available and
I would probably have to offset the lack
of a nitrogen with a mineral source now
in the literature biochar has been noted
to accelerate nitrification for through
different mechanisms by by having a
lining effect by serving phenolic
compounds by providing services for for
autotrophic nitrifiers it's also been
noted to increase the pH so if the
nitrification processes is exacerbating
a soil acidity which could lower the pH
well I think that adding biochar with
that mineral nitrogen should stabilize
the pH generate a lot of nitrate which
is plant available and keep the
phosphorous available so that's what I
thought that I would not see a negative
effect of adding this mineral nitrogen
on soil acidity with biochar I also
thought that in terms of the interaction
between the the amendments I was adding
and the soils I thought that at lower
hht as high as heating temperature the
amendments treated at lower temperatures
and the lighter texture so the sandy
soil would probably promote greater
carbon and nitrogen mineralization I saw
that the stable carbon is much higher at
the higher temperatures and at since
sandier soils that the inclusion of this
amendment would probably increase
surface area allow for more microbial
activity so I expected that and I also
expected that there would be greater
phosphorous availability when I add the
higher heating temperature chars in
acidic soil so that they would buffer
the pH maintaining phosphorous
availability
so to start me and Herald Venice we
collected some soils in western Kenya it
was kind of a wild goose chase
finding the soils that had two soils
that had a low pH and a and a sandy
texture and - so that at a higher pH and
a low me texture or clay texture so we
collected them from three different
watersheds this is the lower yellow
watershed this is the mid yellow
watershed this is the yonder watershed
and these have been very well
characterized by it craft and people
that have worked here before like Doris
Hill tourists and daveed good Enya and
maybe even doubt what I'm not sure
they're they're well-traveled this they
know this area maybe they know some
people and so the so that we collected
from lower yella was a notice all well
these were both Ultra Sol's
according to the Kenyan soil map
although they were very different this
was a cement Smith also sell at like a
sandy textured soil that and I performed
XRD on all the soil so I sort of got the
fingerprint the mineral mineral
fingerprint had a lot of Keio lighted in
highlight this is a very red soil and it
was had a coarser texture with a clay
loam and had a low pH this soil here was
actually a mala Stahl it looked like a
virtus all it was like a black cotton
film they used to grow a lot of cotton
around here
I had an alkaline pH had montmorillonite
caroline ID and a lot of oxides had a
high manganese concentration and as well
that was kind of in the same vicinity we
were lucky we actually got a financial
San in SEPTA's all sorry I totally
messed that out anyway
so this isn't inceptive salt so it
doesn't have a lot of profile
development but it was I did have a
sandy texture was kind of dusty and it
had a you know a fairly non acidic pH
and it had a very high concentration of
extractable manganese as opposed to
using our incubation so the incubation
was like a jar with in a jar with
another little jar that trapped the
carbon dioxide that was coming out of
the soil and so what we did is we is we
incubated four different amendments the
biologically process way so torrefied
ways these two pyrolyzed ways and four
different soils the these four soils
that I just described and I also did the
second experiment where incubated the
pyrolyzed waste with urine in excess
so I have pyrolized waist with urine
just the urine and the nothing and the
amendments were added at about a 10
tonne per hectare ratio and they were
added on a weight basis just point 5
percent by weight so they weren't
normalized to carbon or nitrogen they're
just added on a weight basis and the
urine was added in accordance with what
I would call the resource availability
of urine to feces generated from a fresh
like latrine so I just took the
proportion of human waste and urine
generated on a daily basis and I added
that in that same amount so I added a
lot of nitrogen I added it in excess I
added about 500 kilograms per hectare
and the urine also contained phosphorous
about 30 milligrams or 50 kilograms
phosphorous per hectare and I had enough
charge to where I could destructively
sample at four time points day zero 7:30
and 100 during which I tested this trap
for carbon dioxide and I extracted these
soils the whole entire sample with
potassium chloride to get the mineral
nitrogen when this graph is kind of a
summary of what I found so on the y-axis
you can see this is the phosphorous the
difference of fosters between day 100
and days zero on the x axis I have
mineral nitrogen concentration the
difference between day 100 and a zero
these the shapes of the series they
correspond to these amendments this
upside down triangle is at 200 degree
this diamond is a 300 degree this
forward triangles 500 the box is a
compost and the star is unamended soil
and the magnitude of the series is
representative the magnitude of carbon
respiration and these this is the ultra
salt of Sandy ultra salt and this is
that in sepsis all what that has the
high manganese concentration so what I
see is that the lower temperature indeed
there is a trade-off between highest
heating temperature 200 300 500 and
nitrogen and phosphorus availability
although that doesn't really follow
through with the compost which I also
would have expected to be down here
because again I think the compass is
fundamentally different it's been
altered by it with all the soil that's
been added to it so that's why it
behaves just like the soil and also you
see that the shape of this series
is much bigger because the nitrogen has
been generated through through the cause
of mineralization of the organic matter
and that's why not necessarily this
amendment but in the whole treatment
it's this amendment promoted the
mineralization of a lot of organic
matter and that's why the series is so
big enough so there's so much nitrogen
whereas this amendment it was not
readily did not promote a lot of
mineralization and and phosphorus was
not immobilized but there's still a huge
difference between the results and these
two sites even though they are of a
similar P agent even though they're a
similar texture and I think that's just
because of the mineralogy of the soils
so again I do see this trade-off between
nitrogen and phosphorus with highest
heating temperature and I think it's a
function of the carbon mineralization at
least in the soil the compost did not
compare to the torrefied waste even
though they were at the same temperature
and I think that the explanation might
be the dissolved organic carbon
concentrations in these amendments which
happen to be much higher an order of
magnitude higher for this 200 degree
torrefied waste rather than the compost
I think that's probably what explains
some of these results so if a farmer had
access to at least one of these whether
this or this he might get something good
if he just applies the 500 degree
material the difference in phosphorus
relative to the control soil adds up to
about 22 kilograms of phosphorous per
hectare and these conversions were done
assuming a 15 centimeter depth and a
bulk density of 1.1 and if he just had
this torrefied waste
he'd get about 64 kilograms of nitrogen
per hectare relative to the control soil
so that's not bad
and again I think that the difference
between the results in this soil which
has a similar texture in pH to this soil
is the concentration of ammonium oxalate
extractable amorphous oxide aluminum
iron and manganese which is about two
percent by weight in this soil and it's
0.5 percent of Nestle and so there may
have been phosphorus fixation here
whereas there may have been microbial
immobilization immobilization here those
are just my thoughts for the second
thing I wanted to look at was I wanted
to see if I added the biochar with the
mineral nitrogen what happens to soil
acidity and - phosphorus availabilities
the first thing I noticed
is that adding biochar with with urine
did not increase nitrification or at
least didn't increase the amount of
extractable nitrate they were not
significantly different in this soil and
this this sandy ultra saw and also
adding the biochar with urine did not
help in terms of the pH the pH was very
much acidified with this urine and the
biochar was even a little worse yet so
there was no difference in nitrate or pH
the ratios were probably extremely off
in terms of the amount of nitrogen I
added so yet the phosphorus availability
was not inhibited so this is the same
graph that you just saw with the the
y-axis was phosphorus the difference
between a 100 and a zero mineral
nitrogen de 100 and day zero these are
the series that I had presented and
these two series are this is the biochar
with urine this is just the urine so you
can see that obviously we have a lot of
nitrogen because we've just added a
bunch of nitrogen there's the voucher
doesn't effect the nitrogen
concentrations after a hundred days and
but the and and the phosphorus is not
negatively affected by that exacerbated
acidity so there's still a lot of
phosphorous that that's available
although in this soil with the high
manganese concentrations all of these
amendments performed very poorly
although the urine by itself wasn't that
bad so there's a very big difference
between the soil types and the nitrogen
and the phosphorus response some of the
conclusions I definitely saw a trade-off
between nitrogen and phosphorus with
highest heating temperature but only
among the thermal chemically treated
waste not the compost probably a
function of carbon respiration predicted
by amendment dissolved organic carbon
texture did not play a role not maybe
not even pH necessarily but rather the
concentration of amorphous oxides or
ammonium extractable oxides when they
added this pyrolized waste with urine
did not enhance the subscrible nitrate
did not mitigate acidification although
phosphorus did remain unaffected which
is good so maybe this is a good
amendment maybe pyrolized wasted urine
is a good amendment although we still
obviously have to deal with the
acidification
so my last the last thing I'll talk
about is so we've gone over some
agronomic properties and values we
looked at nitrogen phosphorus
availability and now we're going to talk
about whether we can increase the value
by incorporate
the mineral nitrogen in urine into the
pyrolized way so I'm not just adding it
as a separate liquid but but sort of
intercalating the nitrogen into the
matrix so we can apply it as a granular
fertilizer so that and we've been trying
to develop a process for precipitating
your nitrogen into pyrolyzed waste
urines everywhere so so our goal in
combining mineral nitrogen and urine
with biochar again I want to emphasize
that most of the nitrogen is in
household waste is in urine and all of
most of this nitrogen about 90% is
mineral to plan available whereas the
nitrogen and solid waste is very little
and it's generally organic and the
species of nitrogen urine is urea which
will hydrolyze immediately in soil and
in us in a in a container that you know
is sort of used often with urease into
ammonia and during that process the pH
will go from about 6 to 9 and at 9
you'll end up having about 1/2 ammonia
and half ammonia and a full urine can
smell really bad
and that's other reasons but and so and
so when you talk about like loading
nitrogen onto the biochar matrix you're
dealing with two different forms of
nitrogen you are dealing with ionic
ammonium and then you're dealing with
very reactive ammonia which can be
dissolved in water or it can be in a
gaseous form so some I'll just go over a
few of the mechanisms which are of
interest in trying to you know develop
this process you can just have
nonspecific physisorption you could just
have nitrogen ammonia more ammonia just
sort of being trapped in the pore space
of the biochar we all know that biochar
is renowned for its surface area for
micro porosity so you know you could
just be retaining nitrogen through
occlusion import that the only caveat is
that you since the diameter of ammonia
is about 3 angstroms you need to have
pores that are of a similar magnitude
maybe 10 to 15 10 to 20 angstroms or
else you're not going to Van der Waals
forces are not going to be effective at
all and honestly I don't know what the
micro porosity of my char is I am
assuming it's mesoporous
that may not be very important of a
mechanism another factor that you know
that we
we understand from soils with cation
exchange capacity we could have a
retention of ionic ammonium also weak
bonds on deprotonated hydroxyl groups on
anions maybe sulfur maybe Foss phosphate
we could also have retention at Lamoni
ax which they're strong sorption on
broads and acid groups so because we
know that ammonia has its free electron
pairs that can either receive a proton
and that is a strong surgeon or it can
actually interact with for example in
this carboxylic group the oxygens have
created a dipole so this is very
nucleophilic this is electrophilic and
so this nitrogen could essentially this
ammonia is essentially bond in this
carbonyl group and form an amine group
so this is possible and so this is
strong sorption this is no longer
extractable nitrogen but it could
probably be easily mineralized in soil
so these are different mechanisms that
we can have but again I was mostly
interested in just pushing this to the
max I was like forgot all these surface
functional groups I just want to
precipitate an ammonium salt on the
surface I want to get this I just want
to get a whole bunch of nitrogen on the
surface that we can just put in the soil
so so ammonium salts you have many
ammonium salty of ammonium sulfate you
have struvite that's something that
people have looked into struvite is
ammonium magnesium phosphate and it
often just precipitates in waste water
strains precipitates you know in in pig
manure but the problem with some of
these other ammonium salts is that
you're going to have to you know import
this this counter ion but since we're
dealing with pyrolysis we have a counter
and we have bicarbonate so we have
carbon dioxide carbon tax it is a waste
product of pyrolysis right and since
urine is a pH of 9 if we inject a carbon
dioxide into the urine we are we can
speciate it as bicarbonate maybe
probably not as carbonate so I'm just
saying that why thought will bicarbonate
you know maybe that's a good good
counter ion because anyways we don't
want to spend more money on some of
these other things unlike a sulfate or
or or or magnesium so anyways anyways
but we're just going to go back now
we're going to go through some of these
function mechanisms and look at what we
have okay so now we're going to look at
n loading but via physisorption
and and cation exchange sort of like
Lewis acid-base interactions on oxygen
functional groups at on the 500-degree
material so when I talk about surgeons I
want to maximize all the portfolio of
options because again I have different
types of nitrogen I've got this
heterogeneous surface you know biochar
so here on this y axis I have the
surface area of different human waste
that that's treated at different
temperatures here I have the compost the
torrefied waste the 300 400 500 700 this
is the surface area meter square per
gram you see it goes up the temperature
here I have the cation exchange capacity
millimoles of charge per kilogram and it
goes down because as we as the material
is heated you have a loss of these
functional groups with with heating
temperature but since I'm trying to
diversify the portfolio of options for
sorption I want to get into this sweet
spot area I would I want a little of
everything so I'm going to go with a 500
degree I'm going to say I'm not soaking
on this this is what I'm going to use to
load up the nitrogen because look if I I
can take this value the surface area
value and I can convert it to how many
potential moles of ammonia I can get and
when I do this conversion I mean I can
even get an increase in 4.3% of mineral
nitrogen on the surface just to
physisorption but again you have to
remember that this requires micropores
and I really don't know if I have you
know I have not yet calculated this data
so we'll put that on hold for now in
terms of electrostatics sorption
mechanisms it doesn't seem like the CC
is promising me a lot of retention of
nitrogen the amount of ammonium I can
retain so Sevilla Williams it's only
about increases my mineral nitrogen
content by 0.31% points so doesn't look
very promising so why don't we just look
at the total potential of solving
nitrogen through these acid-base
interactions whether strong function or
weak search and I'm going to say I just
want to look at the oxygenated
functional groups as a proxy for how
much I can even get so here I have this
SK our spectra from wood an oxidized
wood which have a high proportion of
oxygen in functional groups which can
adsorb
ammonia or ammonium and I have my char
the human solid waste these are all
pyrolized with 500 degrees this was
oxidized after pyrolysis so here I have
this carboxylic point at about 1700 wave
number and you can see that in the
oxidized wood it's very strong it's kind
of you know there in wood but it's very
absent in my char I just don't have this
is not a material it's not like wood it
doesn't have these sort of oxygenated
heart it doesn't have these kind of
functional groups in the same proportion
here's a phenolic peak here for o h and
co and again i could see it with wood
but i really don't see it in my char the
office that I actually have this amine p
because i so much minute over an organic
nitrogen so honestly i looking at the
spectra i'm like i don't really know if
this material is going to is going to
really sorb ammonia or ammonium through
these interactions but you know i say
okay let's put that on hold for now and
let's just do an experiment let's just
take a bunch of urine we're going to
take some biochar from Sanergy and we're
going to mix it all together and we're
going to look at how much nitrogen we
can actually sorbonne to the biochar so
I took some fresh urine from Sanergy I
acidified it to a pH of 6 to try to get
all the nitrogen as ammonia
I took some fresh urine that was already
at a pH of 9 through that you know Hydra
through the urease interaction and then
I had a controlled deionized water I
just added the biochar made from Sanergy
at 500 degrees this is the ratio I added
that and I determined the nitrogen
loading by combustion on the stand
analyzer at a craft and so what did I
see I saw that that acidified urine was
the only treatment that actually gave me
a little bit increase in nitrogen I got
a 1.1 percent increase in total nitrogen
assuming it's mineral after this
experiment so what so that means that I
was probably retaining ammonium because
most of the nitrogen was speciated as
ammonia and this actually is greater
than what would have normally been
predicted by cation exchange capacity so
there must be some other mechanisms at
play so now I'm going to move on to what
I thought might be more promising and
that was trying to precipitate a
nitrogen salt on to the surface of the
bike are basically using the biochar
like nucleate
these salts and so I had a system where
I had these jars and I made extensions
with this concentrated nitrogen solution
like a synthetic urine solution and
added a bunch of biochar I injected
carbon dioxide I did a whole bunch of
different configurations of this
experiment to see if anything would
precipitate and what I ended up doing is
I raised the pH of this very
concentrated ammonium chloride with
sodium hydroxide so high and did this
injection with carbon dekhta that I
actually got sodium bicarbonate
precipitation it was very strange but
but that was not what I wanted so
anyways so I eventually settled on that
I really needed to to start moving
towards working in the gas phase and I
probably should have done this with
ammonia but I didn't I kept ammonia
solution because I think that water
especially since the solution was at a
pH of 9.25 ammonia similar to water can
form hydrogen bonds so water is probably
interfering and all of these potential
interactions and so I I needed to
probably need to move towards working in
the gas phase so I used three different
types of by trees wood on oxidized wood
oh sorry this is oxidized wood and I
used the human waste they were all
pyrolized at 500 degrees and my final
configuration was I would I immersed the
char into the inch of this concentrated
nitrogen solution for half an hour and
then I filtered it and then I flushed
carbon dioxide gas over the surface of
the char and what I was hoping to do was
to sequentially sorb nice ammonia and
then on the amine functional groups that
I thought I might be incorporating sort
of carbon dioxide and they make a
ceremony I was trying to do this whole
thing and I didn't really work out so so
what I got so I trying to trying to
eventually basically get like the
precipitation of owning bicarbonate
through gaps through like the sorption
of these of these counter ions what I
saw was that on the y-axis of this graph
I have the percent increase of total
nitrogen from the exposure to the Year
in solution and here I have this
categorical variables of carbon dioxide
exposure to carbon dioxide gas and
nitrogen gas which is just the control
and I have these three different
materials I used my human solid waste
jar the oxidized wood in the unoxidized
wood and I saw that there was
all significant difference in the amount
of nitrogen that was loaded onto the
char this was measured by combustion I'd
see now I mean you can sort of like
you're like oh god of a trend instead of
moving up you know and maybe that's true
and I do think that if I I need to
reconfigure this and I think I might be
able to actually see what I'm trying to
see but as it stands I was definitely
able to increase the nitrogen
concentration and all of it just
exposure to nitrogen to this
concentrated solution for a pretty short
time I was able to increase the total
nitrogen which I'm assuming is mineral
from that solution by between two point
six and five percent evidence of a
slight increase with carbon dioxide
obviously not really but kind of you
know and that there could be
interference with water and so I think
that I we just in a different
experimental design it's just it's not
the right way to do it so and I just
wanted to show what one last thing was I
then took these chars back and went to
see CMR and we looked at the FTIR
spectra of these three different chars
that I've already shown you before so
the blue line is are the control these
are the spectra that you already saw
just the chars without exposure to
anything the red line are the chars that
were immersed in the solution and then
exposed to carbon dioxide through the
flushing and the green line are the sort
of like the control chars that were
exposing the Mersenne the solution that
exposed just to just to just inert
nitrogen and what I saw is that in all
of the chars I got the I was able to
distinguish it there were two new Peaks
that formed at the 1400 area and at the
3,000 area here this area here and all
of the materials sort of more prominent
in the oxidized wood and this 1400 peak
corresponds to ionic ammonium so either
this is sort of crystalline on the
surface or electrostatically absorbed
other people would know better like
Anita and Mike I'm just a novice but I'm
learning
and then these two peaks are so what I
learned is that these two peaks together
can be indicative
fangs of an amine and I did correlate
that my this one website is automatic
that this I could have the corporation
of a mean functional group sort of
through what I had shown you about that
bronsted interaction this ammonia
absorbing to these functional groups
through this nucleophilic addition and
forming these amine groups so I think
that here I might be seeing ammonia
Sorbian hairy ammonium and here I might
be seeing ammonia sore because and
remember the pH was right at the pKa soy
both species in solution and so that's
very interesting because I think with my
carbon dioxide saying I need more of
these functional groups to get this to
work anyways so that is my chair data
and so in conclusion I just want to say
that it's going to say that despite your
proportion of carboxyl and finola oh I
another thing I notice I say this is
that there's a phenolic peak in the in
the wood that here at about 1200 that
disappears after exposure to nitrogen
it's not you don't really see it in the
human waste because I didn't really have
that to begin with anyways so um so the
society or proportion of car box and
phenolic groups humans always served
about 3 percent mineral nitrogen nut 2.6
more than the CC predicts possibly you
know I don't know if it's through
physisorption so is this precipitation
or you know maybe some other things so
I'm just looking at these mechanisms so
anyways and so in conclusion I just want
to say that the pyrolyzed waste noticing
chemically poised to retain ammonia or
ammonium based on acid-base interactions
and less by metals because initially the
fjr spectra should a low proportion of
oxygenated functional groups in CEC
however we are retaining both ammonia
and ammonium so your an absorption
showed retention this first experiment
the ft airport to the incorporation of
amine groups probably through ammonia
ammonium ammonia and precipitation was
not observed visually may not be
possible with water you know in in in an
innocent solution so in the end we
achieved n loading by 2.5% points giving
us our total extractable NPK of two
point five point eight and one it's not
bad for an organic amendment I said it's
worth further iterations because
remember key bear
and the maestro and so I just want to
thank so I'm done and I just want to
thank my advisers yo.hannes
and Harold Rebecca Nelson and I put Beth
mad Becky she was I worked with her in
the Eiger and she's a good friend of
mine and people at Sanergy and the
climate foundation Fausto and Brian and
obviously people in your highness
layman's lab especially Akio and Kelly
at Dorian Rachel who leads so many
things and everyone else has been so
amazing Alyssa Kirsch with whom I did a
lot of these other experiences in
undergrad and others Marie McBride a
when I t-84 him I would always be like
one on that nitrogen and Janice shy REO
over Frank cassavas lab Mike for helping
me analyze the problem the interpret the
spectra Jonathan a Kathy how all these
people people at University of Nairobi
and see now because they let me like run
their machines and mess everything up
and Hugh did an analysis so I just want
and also the funding from the I Gert
poverty reduction and the all these
different things so thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah
yeah okay so okay I really can't speak
from from you know empirical results I I
don't I've never tested this although we
did test PAHs and dioxins and they were
not in the in the chart but in terms of
you know biotics I'm just assuming that
if you go up to 500°
assuming 300 to 500 degrees you'll
probably have the transformation of
xenobiotics probably you know aromatic
rings fusing together now with urine is
another story and so that and that is a
concern because you can pasteurizer and
very easily you can get rid of the the
pathogenic organisms at about 70 degrees
Celsius but but you know we know that
urine has antibiotics so actually the
the process that I'm interested in now
looking at urine is trying to store
nitrogen from the gas phase so you just
avoid the whole issue of xenobiotics is
that yeah that is a problem yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're you're right and in
this paper that I'm writing on the value
I want to subtract from the value the
contribution from sodium because yeah
it's like a it's a deterrent well this
is from the charred waste there's also
sodium in that yeah that's why I think
that there are some issues with
definitely with obviously with sodium
and I was looking at trying to
concentrate urine using porous membranes
and you can get membranes that can allow
sodium is a little bit larger than
ammonium and so yeah I definitely that's
been in the forefront of my mind like I
do have to prevent sodium because even
if you don't have heavy metals that can
ruin everything
yeah I agree with you on that initial
part of the produces a yeah look at all
no yeah yeah yeah yeah no I need to yeah
honestly I'm still figuring out to what
extent I want to like like how far the
cycle should go but I think that that's
yeah very important transportation cause
I haven't incorporated that yet I I
think it's I think it's important I
trying to keep it really simple but I do
think that it's difficult to make an
argument if you're not even considering
how to get the material to the people
that are growing the cross I have to
really consider them
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu